>> IT IS FOURTH OF JULY AND WE
ARE READY FOR TRIVIA SHOW DOWN.
BACK TO TEST OUR KNOWLEDGE
UNPATRIOTIC FUN FACTS LIKE HE
DOES ON THE QUIZ SHOW ONLY ON
FOX NATION.
>> HERE WE GO.
ARE YOU GUYS READY?
WHICH PRESIDENTS FACE IS ON THE
$100,000 BILL.
>> THERE ISN'T A $100,000 BILL.
>> WOODROW WILSON, B WILLIAM
MCKINLEY ORSI, GROVER CLEVELAND.
THE ANSWER IS A COMMODE WOODROW
WILSON.
>> HOW DID YOU KNOW THAT?
>> HE WAS THE WORST PRESIDENT
PAIR.
>> KNOW, THAT WAS OBAMA.
>> WHO WAS THE DECLARATION OF
INDEPENDENCE.
A, B, OR SEE GETTING THOSE CARD
UP.
IT LOOKS LIKE EVERYONE GOT THAT
RIGHT.
GATE.
>> NICE WORK, GUYS.
>> THE QUESTION SO FAR HAVE BEE
GREAT.
WHAT IS THE FIGHT SONG OF THE
U.S. NAVY.
IS IT IN THE NAVY?
ANGERS AWAY?
OR SEMPER BROADUS.
>> WE HAVE GOT SOME B'S AND SOM
SEAS.
IT IS BECOME ANCHORS AWAY.
>> ANCHORS AWAY.
OUR PRODUCER KEEPING SCORE.
WHICH U.S. PRESIDENT WAS BORN O
THE FOURTH OF JULY?
>> BORN ON THE FOURTH OF JULY,
VERY INTERESTING.
I DID NOT THIS ONE.
IT LOOKS LIKE YOU GUYS GOT THIS
ONE, IT IS CALVIN COOLIDGE.
I THINK THE FAMILY FEUD IS IN
OUR FUTURE BRICKEY ARE YOU GUYS
KEEPING SCORE?
I BELIEVE ONE IS IN THE LEAD.
ONE CAN'T WIN THE SHOWDOWN AND
THE QUIZ SHOW.
>> HE IS ONE AHEAD.
>> I THINK IT'S THE AUDIENCE.
HERE WE GO, QUESTION NUMBER FIVE
, ON JULY 4th, 1939 WHICH
BASEBALL LEGEND GAVE HIS FAMOUS
LUCKIEST MAN SPEECH DURING A
CEREMONY AT YANKEE STADIUM.
WAS IT LOU GEHRIG, JOE DIMAGGIO
ORSI, BABE RUTH.
>> AMAZING.
>> WHICH NASA SPACECRAFT LANDED
SAFELY ON THE SURFACE OF MARS O
JULY 4, 1997.
THAT WAS MY HEYDAY.
DISCOVERY, GALILEO, OR
PATHFINDER.
ALL THE CARDS ARE UP AND THE
ANSWER IS C, PATHFINDER.
>> SPACE CAMP CAMP PAID OFF.
>> LEARNING TOO MUCH ABOUT YOU.
>> GUYS, WE HAVE A THREE WAY TIE
.
DANA, ONE.
>> TIDE, IS THIS WHERE WE GO TO
THE TIEBREAKER?
DIGGY GREG, YOU CAN PARTICIPATE.
>> I WILL CHEER ON THE
PARTICIPANTS.
>> HOW MANY HOT DOGS ARE
CONSUMED EVERY FOURTH OF JULY?
>> EVERY FOURTH OF JULY.
150 BILLION?
200 MILLION?
OR C 50 MILLION.
>> WHAT KIND OF HOTDOGS?
COULD GET THEY DON'T SPECIFY IN
THE QUESTION WHETHER IT'S IN TH
UNITED STATES.
>> SOME PEOPLE 100 HOTDOGS OF
PERSON.
>> ALL KINDS OF HOTDOGS.
>> HOW ABOUT MEATLESS HOTDOGS.
>> WHAT KIND OF KIDS LOVE ARMOR
HOTDOGS?
THAT KIND OF KID.
SKINNY KIDS.
KIDS WITH CHICKENPOX.
>> A, B, OR C, WARD IS THE
WINNER.
>> I WROTE IT TO.
>> I WAS LOOKING FOR AND A.
>> HOW DOES THE SONG GO?
>> IT IS THE ONE.
DID YOU WRITE THAT DOWN?
>> EVER DONE SEE.